Just like any part of a film, the cast is
always subject to change until the movie is
complete.
When brainstorming the right actors and actresses
for each role, filmmakers can go through several
names, and Hollywood history is full of interesting
“what if?”
alternate realities.
Some of the biggest movies of all-time could
have looked very different if certain parts
were handed out to someone else.
At times, it’s difficult to say if that
would have been for the better or worse, but
it’s always fascinating to think about.
Here are 10 actors who missed out on huge
roles for strange reasons.
Spider-Man
Elizabeth Banks was only 26 years old when
she tested for the role of Mary Jane Watson
in Sam Raimi’s first Spider-Man film.
She was less than 15 months older than lead
Tobey Maguire, so it was puzzling when she
was told she was “too old” to play MJ.
The part eventually went to Kirsten Dunst,
who was just 20 when the movie reached theaters
in 2002.
Though Banks didn’t get the role she wanted,
she did land a supporting part in the trilogy,
playing Daily Bugle secretary Betty Brant.
It’s clear that Raimi enjoyed her talent
and wanted to include her in his movies somehow.
Ferris Bueller’s Day Off
Matthew Broderick IS Ferris Bueller.
It’s impossible to separate actor from character,
so it’s a little jarring to consider that
he wasn’t the only choice for the role.
Johnny Depp was originally offered the role
of the troublesome teenager, but had to turn
it down because the production schedule conflicted
with some of his other projects.
That opened the door for Broderick to step
in, and a cinematic legend was made.
Depp can act circles around people, but it’s
tough to envision him mastering the art of
breaking the fourth wall in such a charming
fashion.
Broderick is what made the film what it is
today.
Casino Royale
When a new James Bond was needed for reboot
Casino Royale, EON Productions considered
several names, including some A-listers.
Hugh Jackman could have donned the tux, but
he turned down the role of 007 because he
already had Wolverine.
He felt portraying two classic characters
would have boxed him in too much, due to the
large commitments franchise films present.
In the end, it may have been a good move.
Daniel Craig is considered one of the better
Bonds, and Jackman carved out a diverse career
between X-Men appearances.
Interestingly enough, both roles could be
looking for a new actor soon.
The Terminator
Arnold Schwarzenegger became an action icon
with his terrifying performance as the cybernetic
Terminator in James Cameron’s seminal sci-fi
work.
But if the filmmakers stuck to the first pick,
history would have remembered the movie very
differently – for all the wrong reasons.
The producers initially wanted football star
O.J. Simpson, but then decided against it
because they thought the charismatic running
back couldn’t be a convincing killer.
Real life had an ironic way of proving Cameron
wrong, but luckily The Terminator lives on
as a one of the best films ever made.
If Simpson was the T-800, it may not be as
revered as it is today.
The Silence of the Lambs
Silence of the Lambs pulled off the rate feat
of winning in all the major Oscar categories
the year it was released, meaning the role
of Clarice Starling netted Jodie Foster a
Best Actress trophy.
Foster was always the screenwriter’s choice
for the part, but director Jonathan Demme
wanted Michelle Pfieffer.
She was offered Clarice, but Pfieffer turned
it down because she wanted to avoid the amount
of violence and gore that was in the film.
It wasn’t all bad for Pfieffer, who turned
many heads as Catwoman in 1992’s Batman
Returns.
She still got to leave her mark on a popular
film.
Django Unchained
Most actors would kill to work with Quentin
Tarantino, who consistently writes crackling
dialogue and crafts masterful films.
But Will Smith didn’t sign up when he had
the chance.
Tarantino had the Fresh Prince he mind for
the role of Django in 2012’s Django Unchained,
but Smith turned the part down because he
felt Dr. King Schultz, not Django, was the
movie’s real lead.
Smith begged for Tarantino to revise the script
so it was Django who killed Calvin Candie,
but the director refused.
The role ended up going to Jamie Foxx, who
did an excellent job opposite Christoph Waltz,
who won Best Supporting Actor for his turn.
Star Wars
David Prowse gave Darth Vader his intimidating
physique, but his accent made the Dark Lord
less threatening.
George Lucas knew that Vader’s lines would
have to be overdubbed by another actor for
the finished film.
Looking for someone with a powerful voice,
Lucas first considered Orson Welles, but then
decided against it because he thought Welles’
vocals would be too recognizable for the viewers.
Of course, he eventually landed on James Earl
Jones, whose baritone became ingrained in
popular culture as one of the definitive sounds
in Star Wars lore.
He’s set to return in this December’s
Rogue One, and fans cannot wait.
The Blind Side
Its status as an Oscar contender was mocked
by some, but there was no denying The Blind
Side had a lot of fans within the Academy.
Its touching true story is the stuff classic
inspirational sports films are made of, and
Sandra Bullock received an Oscar for her performance.
But another Hollywood sweetheart could have
had the trophy if things played out differently.
Julia Roberts was originally offered the role
of Leigh Anne Tuohy, but turned it down so
she could work on Valentine’s Day, one of
Gary Marshall’s infamous holiday themed
films.
Roberts may not have chosen wisely, but at
least she has an Oscar of her own for Erin
Brockovich.
Avatar
Whenever an expensive original project is
coming through the pipeline, executives look
for any way they can to increase its appeal.
When it came to casting James Cameron’s
fantasy epic Avatar, the studio considered
stars such as Matt Damon and Jake Gyllenhaal
for the lead, Jake Sully.
Cameron took the opposite route and went with
the then unknown Sam Worthington.
Worthington may not have broken out as the
next great leading man, but he was solid in
the role and will be a main player in the
forthcoming sequels.
And when you consider Damon and Gyllenhaal
are doing just fine without Pandora, everything
worked out for the best.
Deadpool
Ryan Reynolds was locked into Deadpool from
the day he was born, but he needed a supporting
cast.
Originally, Olivia Munn was offered to play
Wade Wilson’s girlfriend Vanessa, a part
that eventually went to Morena Baccarin.
Munn turned it down because she didn’t just
want to be a love interest.
She stayed within the same franchise and chose
to play Psylocke in X-Men: Apocalypse.
Ironically, Psylocke was seen as one of the
weaker elements of that film, while the relationship
between Wade and Vanessa in Deadpool was praised
for its heart.
If Munn had a mulligan, maybe she’d pick
Deadpool.
Those are our picks for actors who missed
out on big roles for weird reasons.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones do you wish had actually happened?
Let us know in the comments and don’t forget
to subscribe!